e herkese merhaba Tekrar be şimdi
İlizyon Aslında bildiğiniz gibi bir
yanılsama gerçekliğin doğru bir şekilde
algılanamadı bir duyu yanılsaması ve
birçok da teknik tanımı var ama
baktığınızda ilizyonu ne bizim
hayatımızın merkezinde çok fazla yer var
baktığınızda beğenilme de bizim
Hayatımızda önemli bir yer tutuyor ve
Biz sürekli Birileri bizi beğensin
istiyoruz ve like lar peşinde koşuyoruz
ya da takipçi kovalıyoruz hayatımızı
takipçilerimize göre yaşamaya başlıyoruz
bununla yetinmiyor Uz bir taraftan
hayatımızda çok sert bir performans
Dünyası var ve sürekli
bu agresif bir şekilde performansının
performansımızı sürdürme zorunluluğu
yaşıyoruz Bu da hayatımızdaki temeli
lezyonlardan biri bir diğeri ise
baktığınızda kartvizit lerimiz
kimliğimiz olmuş ve kimliklerimizi de
kartvizit lerimize meze ediyoruz Bu da
deneyim dediğimiz en büyük İlizyon
onlardan biri ve son olarak da aslında
güç ve imkan için hayatımızı
şekillendiriyoruz bazen de hayatımızdan
kendimizden ve kendi gerçekliğimiz den
feragat ediyoruz Aslında ilizyonu teknik
tanımının haricinde bizim hayatımızın
merkezinde Bugün de Yaşadığımız en temel
ilizyonlar Bunlar bugün biraz daha iyi
anlamak için birkaç detaya girelim
sanalla gerçeğin birbirinden çok net
bu bağını kopardı bir zamandayız Öyle
bir zamanda eski gerçeklikte kalanlar
zamanı yaşıyorlar hakkıyla hayatlarını
yaşıyorlar ama gücü yetmeyenler gücü
yetmeyenler ise sanalın ilizyona düşüyor
Ve baktığınızda bu insanlar sürekli
sanal dünyanın ne kadar önemli olduğunu
vurgulamak zorunda kalıyorlar ve Buna ek
olarak da baktığımızda hayatımızda çok
fazla imajların olduğunu görüyoruz
kavramların altının boş aldığını görürüz
ve bizim algıladığımız Dünya ile Gerçek
dünya arasındaki bu fark arttıkça
bildiğimiz kavramlarında altı boşalıyor
ve bu vesile ile baktığımızda şunu
görüyoruz Bir nevi altı boşalmış
kavramlardan felsefesiz leşme yaşıyoruz
felsefesiz leşme ile birlikte yi
bu hayatımızda imajlar filtreler ve o
filtrelere göre yaşanmış deneyimler ön
plana çıkıyor bir mekana giderken o
mekanın fotoğrafı nasıl durur
Instagram'da diye ona göre mekan
seçiyoruz ya da kendimizi sosyal medyada
paylaşırken en doğru filtreyi bulmaya
çalışıyoruz ve oradaki imajın
gerçekliğine inanıyoruz ve dünyamızda o
şekilde algılıyoruz Aslında
baudrillard'ın söylediği gibi bir nevi
hiper gerçeklik yaşıyoruz öyle bir hiper
gerçeklik ki gerçeğe referans duymak
ihtiyacı hissetmeyen Hatta gerçeği
kendini açıklamak için sahteye referans
duymak ihtiyacı hissettiği bir hiper
gerçeklik yaşıyoruz ve bu hiper
gerçeklik içerisinde birçok sanal
duygumuz var sanal insanlar var sana
travmalar var sanal aşklar var sana hiç
Kiler var sanal mekanlar var sanal
sevişmeler var ve sanal travmalar
ve bunların hepsini ziyadesiyle
yaşıyoruz Bunların hepsi bizim Aslında
baktığınızda genel İlizyon bağlarımızı
oluşturuyor Peki iyice bir şey soracağım
Bu ne demek oluyor benim ya ben nasıl
biz nasıl Yaşıyoruz bir bu ilizyonu
Aslında bu bahsettiğim İlizyon evreni
bir iklim gibi düşünmek lazım buradaki
soruda şu bu iklimden ben nasıl
etkileniyor ve bu iklimin içerisinde
spesifik olarak benim rolüm L bunun
içinde birazcık daha derine inmek lazım
kendi içlerinde bize yemek lazım
baktığınızda burada insanın gölgesi
mı kendisiyle Ne kadar mesafeli olursa
Yani siz bölgenize ne kadar yüz
çevirirseniz gölgeniz o kadar karanlık
ve o kadar da yoğun olur ve bu vesileyle
o karanlık olan gölge genelde yüz
çevrildiği için hep dışarıya bakar
Dışarıya itilir dışarıya itildiği için
Biz her zaman için karanlığı suçu
beğenmediğiniz şeylere dışarıda alırız
ve dışarıda aradığımız için hep Ötekiler
Onlar Bunlar kötü yapıyorlar ve tamamen
topu dışarıda tutmaya çalışırız bu
Aslında bir nevi Gölgeyi yüz çevirme ve
gölge ile yüzleşme mevzusu Bununla
birlikte Aslında baktığınızda insanın
gölgesini kontrol altında tutan kişilik
bölümüne de persona diyor Yok ve Pers
ona Bir perspektiften de bizim toplum
tarafından kabul
bu temizi sağlayan toplumun beğenisini
almak için yüzünüze taktığımız bir maske
aslında gölgenizi filtreleyen bir Maske
ve hayatta da bizi için toplumun
içerisinde var olmak için önemli bir
maske Şimdi biz persona mızı
tanımladıktan sonra biz olmak toplum
tarafından beğenilen ve olmak
istediğiniz kişiye çok fazla kendimizi
özdeşleştirir diniz zaman egomuz daha
fazla şişiyor ve benim egonla personam
yani kimliğim birbirine yakışıyor ve bu
da aslında bakıldığında benim kendimi
çok beğenmeme ve çok önemsememe yol
açıyor ve her beğeniye muhtaç kişide
baktığınızda her zaman için buradaki
ilizyona daha hayran olan kişi oluyor ve
bu o kadar mükemmel bir dünya ki benim
için ben negatifleri eleştirileri hiçbir
zaman görmek istemiyorum ve
Evet şimdi sürekli olumlama yapıyorum
hikayeni tarafına bakıyorum ne kadar iyi
olduğunu gösteriyorum ve ne kadar iyi
olduğuna Bakıyorum bu beğenilme hikayesi
öyle bir iptilâ ki baktığınızda sürekli
beğeniyi alabilmeniz için siz mevcut
performansınızın üstünde muazzam bir
performansı sürekli sürdürmek zorunda
kalıyorsunuz ki sürekli beğenirim
Dolayısıyla performansı Bu bağlamda
hayatımızı kritik bir yere oturuyor ya
şimdi şu fotoğrafı görünce aklıma şey
geldi Yüce değer veriyor yani değil mi
bu buffering diyor Yani aslında bir
error veriyoruz Yani bir sıkıntı var bir
farkındayız ya da değiliz değil mi bana
öyle gibi geliyor bazı farkındayız
ağzınız değil sanki Evet aslında bu
error larda şöyle bu Az önce bahsettiğim
gölgeye personae Go akabinde beğenilme
hikayesiyle birlikte bunları mağaza
Tabii ki bünyede çıktıları oluyor
o en önemli çıktısı da beğenilmeyen
muhtaç insanların sürekli beğeni arayan
insanların her zaman bünyelerinde
maskelenmiş Muazzam nitelikli bir
depresyon vardır ama bunu kendilerine
bile çok fazla itiraf edemezler ve bir
taraftan baktığınızda Siz sürekli bu
performansını sergilerken kendinize de
İlizyon temel hedefler koyarsınız
aslında hiç ulaşamayacağınız hayal
ettiğiniz Ama artı dolu olmayan hedefler
koyarsınız ve Bu hedeflere değer
işlemediğiniz zaman kendinizi yetersiz
hissetmeye başlarsınız yok
yetersizlikten dolayı da bir taraftan
baktığınızda kendinize yabancılaşmaya
başlarsınız kendine yabancılaşma da
kendinden kopmanın en temel
enstrümanlarının başında geliyor Ve
tabii ki bununla birlikte bir yalnızlık
hissedilmeye başlanır Ama bu Yalnızlık
da hiçbir zaman itiraf edilmez Çünkü hiç
kimse yalnızım demeyi sevmem
Ya aslında yalnızdır ama yalnızlıktan
Kaçmak için hiçbir zaman yalnız kalmaz
onun için Ya sana gider yada sana
arkadaşlıklara Sana ilişkilere sana
dostluklara gider yalnız kalamayan insan
sürekli meşgul çalan telefon gibidir ama
kendi bile bunun farkında değildir Ve
tabii ki bu kadar İlizyon İstilası
varken üzerinize hiç bilmediğiniz bir
hayat bu kadar Çok parametre ile
gelirken sizin için en kolay çözüm
eleştirel düşünce şüphe ve bu tip kaygı
üretmektir Dolayısıyla bünye bu kadar
belirsizliği kaldıramadığı için sürekli
her şeye herkese ve tüm olaylara karşı
şüpheci bakar ve eleştirel bakar
eleştirel değerlendirir Bu da bizim
bünyemizde sürekli olarak kaygıyı
artırır ve bununla birlikte Kaygımız da
artıyor Bir taraftan da çok ciddi
Beğenilmek istiyoruz ve beğenin
Bu nasıl bir reflexes var ve bazında
beğenilme refleksi olan yine bu insanlar
burada baktığınız zaman sürekli Has
peşinde koşmaya çalışırlar ve o hazzı
hiçbir zaman ertelemek istemezler ve bu
hazzı ertelerken de baktığınızda sürekli
bir performans sergilemek isterler bu
çünkü hazdan mutluluk referansını
birbirlerine Entegre etmişlerdir gerçek
mutluluk referansını kaybetmiş insanlar
sürekli Has peşinde koştuğu zaman işte o
zaman o hazzın kölesi olurlar ve daha
sonra da daha ruhsal sıkıntılar yaşamaya
başlarlar ve nihai olarak da
baktığınızda Tüm bunları arka arkaya
eklediğimizde bizim o personal hızla
gerçek kimliğimiz arasındaki
dalgalanmadan dolayı biz farklı
maskelerle farklı ortamlarda farklı
kişilere karşı farklı şekilde davranırız
ve bunu
o profesyonel yapınız ki bir yerden
sonra kendimize yabancılaşma daha azami
düzeye gelir ve biz Aslında fark etmeden
mış gibi yaşamaya başlarız şimdi Özünde
burada bu kadar İlizyon İstilası varken
en büyük soru sorulması gereken en büyük
soru bunun ne kadar farkındayız ve
gerçekten farkında mıyız Aslında
baktığımızda genel olarak farkında
olmadığımız görüyoruz Bu akışa bu
ilizyona kapıldı ımızı kaldığımızı
kandırdı ımızı kendimizi kaldırdığımız
öncelikle ve daha sonra da az önce ifade
ettiğim gibi mış gibi yaşadığımızı
görüyoruz Düzel Peki ne olacak
bu ne oldu gördüm Muharrem'i ne olacak
yapacağız şu Aslında buradaki en kritik
konu soru sorabilmek soru sorabilmek çok
önemli bir görgü E insanın var oluşundan
beri Merak sorma çok değerli bir
yaklaşım Çünkü her soru baktığınızda bir
arayış soru sormak olmak demektir soru
sormak yaşamak demektir ve yaşadığını
daha soğuk hissetmek demektir Peki daha
somut ne yapacağız Ne yapacağız dersek
burada Aslında Öncelikle bizim bu
ilizyonlar ımıza bir format atmamız
gerekiyor ilizyonları doğru şekilde
anlayıp akabinde o ilizyonlar A1 format
atmamız gerekiyor ilizyonları
formatladıktan sonra akla gelen ilk soru
Ben Hard diskin boş ne yükleyeceğim ve
nasıl bir donanım yüklemem lazım ki bu
İlizyon istilasının içerisinde benq
bu farkında olan ve kendini yaşayan bir
birey olayım Buradaki en kritik
yüklenmesi gereken konu Aslında çok
temel beşeri bir bilgi yani hayat
bilgisi Hayat bilgisinden de kasıt okuma
okuma eylemi öncelikli olarak neyi okuma
dünyanın genelindeki Makro faktörleri
okuma trendleri okuma toplumu okuma işi
okuma ve en önemlisi insanı okuma
Dolayısıyla kendini okuma akabinde
okuduğunu anlama ve onu deneyime dahil
etme farklı işler farklı İnsanlar farklı
tutkular farklı mekanlar ve farklı
şeyler deneyimleme ve okuduğumu
deneyimlerle birleştirme ve tabii ki
bunu yaparken de bunları gerçek manada
anlayabilmeye çalışma Şimdi ben bunu
okudum anladım deneyin diyorum
bu en kritik Aslında bu Vizyon İstilası
içerisinde en kritik kavram dertlenme
Çünkü siz her şeyi Muazzam
anlayabilirsiniz herşeyi çok güzel
yapabilirsiniz ama bir konuyu tutkuyla
dertle Nerek takıntı haline getirmeden
gerçekten ben bunu yapmalıyım mı bütün
hücrelerinde hissetmeden yaptığınız
zaman mutlaka bu eksik kalıyor ve
mutlaka bünyenize Entegre olmuyor
kanınıza karışmıyor Onun için buradaki
en kritik konu dertlenme Şimdi genelde
çok biz severiz madde bağımlılığını
nasıl madde bağımlılığı sen bunları
anlattığını ettin ama bana somut bunu
maddeler halinde ver ya da maddeler
halinde daha detaylı neler söylersin
dersek o
11'inci maddenin şu soracaksın ve
sorgulayacak sın bu çok önemli merak
edecek ve dertlenecek sin sabırlı olacak
ve Sebat edeceksin kendini insanı hayatı
ve kitabı okuyacaksın kendini
eksikliklerinde ve eziklerin de kabul
edeceksin ki İlizyon istilasında ezberi
bozmanın en önemli ön şartı kendini bir
şekilde kabul edebilme hazlara değil
hedeflere odaklanacak sın Yok hedefle
hayatım dair gerçek hedefler olacak bak
nefes alacaksın ve nefes almayı
bileceksin
bu sevinci başkalarını ve varlıklarını
sömürmek de değil vermekte ve
paylaşmakta bulacaksın akışa
kapılmayacaksın kendi akışına sahip
olacaksın
bu hayattaki amacını bulacak bilecek
anlayacak ve bu amacı merkezinde
merkezine alacaksın kendi hayatını
kısıtlayarak başkalarının hayatlarına
baskı yapmayacaksın istediğin
istemediğinin farkında olup Hayır demeyi
bileceksin ki bu aslında bu Az önce
tanımladığım evrende en zor
yapabildiğimiz konu ben bunu istemiyorum
diyebilmek Ben bunu istiyorum diyebilmek
ve en nihayetinde hayır diyebilmek
kendini aldatma ihtiyacını duymayacak
olgunluk seviyesine gelmeye çalışacak ve
putlarından arayacaksın kendini çok
sevmeyi bırakacak insan varoluşunu
sınırlarını ve kısıtlarını kavrayacak
sın ve bununla alakalı da tabii ki
dertlenecek Scene
bu elde ettiğin elinde sadece sana
mutlulukların kalacağı başarı olarak
larını kötülük ile takas etmeyeceksin
gelip geçici hevesleri bir kenara
bırakıp gerçek tutkulara yenileceksin
insanı şaşkına çeviren şeylerin
kalabalıkta değil sakin ve sessiz
yerlerde olduğunu aklından çıkarma ya
caksın Ümit peşinde koşarken Gelecekle
zehirlenmiş bir halde kendini şimdiden
ve gelecekten sorumlu hissederek
kötülüğün hayatına girmesine izin
vermeyeceksin sürekli Hazar ay anlı'dan
arayanlardan olmayacaksın ve Has
arayanların peşinden gitmeyeceksin ve
son olarak d'orphee tapınağının
kapısında milattan önce 700. yüzyılda
yazılmış ve milattan önce 700. yüzyıldan
bu zamana kadar hiç değişmemiş hala 2020
lerde bile an
çok kuruyan ve ileride anlamını
koruyacak en kritik madde kendini
olacaksın Dolayısıyla tüm bunların
hepsini bünyemize doğru bir şekilde
Entegre edebilirsek En azından Entegre
etmeye namzet olursak biz bu ilizyonları
doğru şekilde yönetebiliriz ve bu
perspektifte de kendi geleceğimizi ve
toplumun geleceğini doğru ve sağlıklı
bir şekilde şekillendirebiliriz diyerek
teşekkür ediyoruz uza